my fingers in there hello Isaac yeah
where did we just arrived at the airport
we're at the airport why are we at their
work going to New York New York just me
my boy sorry daddy you can't come Joker
yeah hold down the fort
yeah hold up I mean say bye to Daddy and
he says daddy man
[Music]
telling them what are you plotting
[Music]
you wanted Isaac to experience New York
okay for Hong Kong Christmas vacation
and so we didn't want to miss first in
New York of the New York Hong Kong as
comparisons that's already
daddy because he is doing a writer's
retreat thing the whole
and ready for movie the entire weekend
he's gonna be stuck over there that's
why we had this weekend where
[Music]
[Music]
thank square baby
you're seeing well and yawning at the
same time you're tired you know it's
almost 2 a.m. here yeah yeah that time
we're gonna check out tomorrow you got
it busy there we go
oh I missed your face dang I just saw
the back of your head we got bug bed
dude yeah of course
you cutie you like it yeah it's like I
booked us this hotel room with bunk beds
yeah once I saw this as an option I was
like there's no way we can get this room
this is pretty cool so you guys have
sleepover Marisa no hotel room that is
bunk bed dude and we each have TVs -
that's pretty cool man comfy life live
in the light see what kind of view we
got
good what oh it's a good one well let me
turn off the light so you can see the
thing it's pretty cramped in here oh my
goodness oh I hit my chin but let me see
this turn off the light look at that
view
not bad not bad
alright now we got to get ready for bed
because tomorrow what are we doing its
glory yeah we're gonna go visit the
Statue of Liberty which I'm super
excited for because I've only been to
New York once and that was many years
ago we came for New Year's 2012
going into 2013 and we got to see the
ball drop it was so cool
so that was wintertime so I'm really and
looking forward to seeing what New York
is like now in the summer but anyway to
get going to sleep see you guys morning
good morning morning first day New York
dude look I just pickpocketing you and
you have nothing in there yeah so what's
your pickpocket nothing you're
practicing the pickpocketing prevention
by getting in the mind of a pickpocket
er yeah I knew that I need to pretend I
write any pickpocketer so they they
won't be [ __ ] you know thank you thank
you look at that
that's our daytime view so today on the
agenda is the only thing on the agenda
is sexual Liberty that's the only thing
I really planned and then we're gonna
see where we get lost today
are you trying to tickle me particularly
[Music]
nice being here and with such nice
weather last time I was here I was
freezing people looking before walk in
here I'm trying to get b-roll like daddy
since he's not here
I gotta be daddy
[Music]
[Applause]
and Katie and I were waiting right over
there we were waiting for like 13 hours
I think
so it's really nice to be back in nice
weather so it was freezing I was hungry
and I'm tired kind of like what I was
explaining right now these dark circles
and ten he was so excited last night
that we didn't go to sleep until close
to 3:00 a.m. and we woke up I got 9 a.m.
so
tired we haven't had breakfast yet we
want to eat
some pizza for breakfast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey nobody could cross off New Jersey on
the map because we had like a
scratch-off mat so we've crossed off all
the places we've been so far and now we
can cross off New Jersey this camp sorry
right now we're heading to the very
ticket place to get tickets to go to
send you Liberty
we're gonna see the Statue of Liberty
and we get to go up the pedestal you
believe we're standing in a whole
different state and you could see a
whole nother state just right over there
I neither state would say to that
if only daddy was here to take place of
the wine that we could just sit down I
know that's all I have handy to have two
parents on a trip I mean you could go
sit down and I could stand in line no
you don't leave your mom alone you sweet
boy
this line is just to get through
security behind that building right
there it's a whole another line to get
into the ferry we're gonna be here
awhile
[Music]
it's really hard like do everything
one-handed
oh look at the American flag right
behind you it's very patriotic very
appropriate
while we're heading to the Statue of
Liberty does it look like Hong Kong Oh
baby like put like ten of those together
in that Hong Kong yeah it's huge 20 BC
waiting on common because I do wanna
most straights to see Lady Liberty
[Music]
nice and refreshed whoa whoa dude look
at that beautiful all my goodness I get
to see her right in front of my eyeballs
this is awesome last time we were here
was right after Hurricane sandy so they
closed this entire island but we did get
to see her through like a boat ride
around the island but now I'm actually
here going up to the pedestal baby
[Music]
it's like really
that is a ton of people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's hard to climb upstairs or
downstairs
you were already complaining about
walking when we got to the park just to
get up to this Barry your time you would
rather climb upstairs random hey would
you look at that and now we're done
[Music]
that's the World Trade Center right
there your first New York subway
New York City red
[Music]
[Applause]
like I'm walking here I'm crawling here
so we were walking to the subway Isaak
realized that my first was open but like
I know
joy can up Prince Street keeps up but
look at that line that's just too crazy
we're not gonna wait for that I'm hungry
now home so we're gonna look for
somewhere else
[Music]
very sad computer age
[Applause]
up close in the root be ready for dinner
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna shoot this ice-cream
sputters like how could we not walk in
there and get some ice cream I love this
time of day this is like the perfect
lighting too and then all these
buildings like everyone everywhere we go
it's a nice backdrop
what is that look floor one step on that
now we're heading back to the Times
Square area so we can get to check it
out during the nighttime and then we're
gonna call it a night and
he loves me blogging cuz he's just
eating away at that ice cream now we're
checking out what store
[Music]
look Isaac that gutter right over there
is where we were we were in a gutter
trying to wait for the ball to drop well
actually it's a bigger head
wrong corner yeah this gutter right here
that's the gutter where we were waiting
for the ball to drop right
you don't care anymore help you're like
guidon stop talking about your previous
trip and enjoy the one [ __ ] on now
with me you don't care you just want
advance you know a lot of people are
probably watching your dinner hey P P P
P honey won't wave and no one cares hey
nobody gets a walk through Times Square
it
[Music]
[Music]
ready to go to Central Park
trying to keep my backpack safe yeah of
course thank you
getting street smarts
like mommy's we're going to be put in
front
we're gonna be doing a bike tour of
central hey there we go you excited to
see Central Park dude yeah we're gonna
ride through it to our bike tour events
I know that's a long time thing you're
like dang it hey at least you're not
gonna be walking
[Music]
it's America
oh man listen too early for the bike
tour we had to like super rush to catch
up and my quads are burning what do you
think it's been to work so far Vivek
beautiful you know we were actually
thinking about either bikes or the boat
and then we ended up going with the
bikes because then we could see pretty
much the little part Isaac's in his own
little world
he's a preteen now so he's not trying to
talk anymore he's just like in his own
head
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we just finished a bike tour
how was it it was awesome yeah there's a
favorite part basically riding the bike
already member every time we rode our
bikes
but now we're gonna try to go to the
Empire State Building you get
butterflies me oh my God look at this
tiny little piano oh oh you wanna get it
do you need to play on that oh you need
all the keys look at you Pro man I would
die if I got that piano that's so cute
oh you're ready for them crazy because
you've been asking me since yesterday
we're gonna throw the impersonally we're
getting their bravery
we made it to the Empire State Building
you ready to go see what the view looks
like from the top let's do it I like how
you have your hands on your waist you're
like ready
[Music]
yeah there's a whole bunch of different
movies about don't eat anywhere other
than
[Music]
day three our last full day here in New
York the today's plan is to first class
some bagel breakfast and then go to
their living memorial and then go to or
electric one World Trade Center I think
was telling me how there's like a screen
on the elevator and it shows you how old
a building or but I don't even know that
on the elevator it shows you the dates
and you can just see it all the least
when you're going up building cool when
you finally make it once everybody is
out of the elevator the screams - look
out they're all closed and they can open
up yeah so we're gonna check that
[Music]
you turn at the end of the vision to be
heard of what happened on 9/11 yeah
sometimes yeah sometimes so right here
where there's this huge empty space in
this guy that's where the towers used to
be so right now we're gonna go walk over
and they made these like fountain to
show where the towers used to stand
everyone's names that passed away is on
the side of the fountain
[Music]
alright so we just visited the museum it
was so like earth-shattering to relive
and like to see all that because I
remember it when it happened I was about
I was 11 years old
Buster's well showing everything Issac
and like telling him like oh my gosh
like this actually happen in our country
not that long ago I choked up so many
times I'm like don't cry don't cry don't
cry so hard I think it's a really
important thing to come and show I'd
like this this part of our American
history
it was very emotional and shocking to
see like all those people hurt when I
heard the phone
[Applause]
Oh
it's like a very ancient
yeah but it wasn't in my view
lunch
and after we're gonna check out the One
World Trade Center this is cool
chick-fil-a has Group CD
we shoulda ate here sorry I know we were
eating on the second floor I had no idea
there was a roof seating but then right
when we were leaving these ladies were
coming down from the elevators they're
like oh yeah you should check out the
roof like
to play on the roof
now I was like her cuz he did say he's
like oh yeah I merely had a receding
from like awkward
Oh
[Music]
what do you think eat I'm always scared
that those things are gonna hit me for
every time this beats time I get up wow
this is cool
whoa whoa whoa what happened miss are
you okay so pretty
[Music]
welcome to one world observatory
how do you know all of this they need to
know that you know folks experience the
infinite facets of the city beneath us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now we invite you to enters of
London world observatory through the
doors on the city tell me about that
yeah like yeah I miss home videos like
the whole body laughing and it's you're
gonna be my tour guide you're so cute
Vivek pretty amazing huh which would be
like better than a very state buildings
view or this view I know me too
in the in place
Lawrence really went up to the east
Explorer yeah but in this one were along
I could tell you it doesn't look that
different maybe this was the highlight
totally surpassed expectations
[Applause]
[Music]
one world
that was cool
all right so we're waiting in line for
this is Doradus diner
fifthly the famous because they sing and
perform
while you eat so it's like a really cute
little diner and the performances are
pretty good last time I came Oh with
Casey and really nice really cool but
there's a really long
so we're waiting right now we miss papa
yeah
[Music]
it's just so New York to me Steve Rosie
wrestling with the Sun wrestling
tongue wrestling it means from the male
you notice
[Applause]
you're gonna love
now with your progress
[Applause]
[Music]